foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
foreign
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Elon Musk rocket
Goes Up In Smoke
how appropriate on 420 right
you know at a lot of I always say Donald
Trump everything he touches turns the
liquid [__]
you know I say that Rick Wilson says
everything Trump touches dies which I
mean you know that's sort of correct it
it's close but everything Trump touches
turns to liquid [__] but it's beginning
to rub off on Elon every [__] thing
this guy touches turns to Absolute 100
liquid [__]
it's rough on these guys you know what I
mean these people who placate to the
right Wingers I mean the rake stepping
doesn't stop
and this morning
SpaceX what what they what they [__]
call it a rapid unscheduled disassembly
you mean that [__] blew up
come on call it what it is stop [__]
around Elon stop bullshitting us and a
lot of people are like hey um you know
it's a success which I mean I get it
it's one of the largest you know hunks
of [__] metal that anyone's tried to
launch in the space but it didn't work
it didn't work he failed again really
and and I I stress the Again part
hmm it [__] blew up in the air
it's Elon I mean he again he blows
everything up
[__] Tesla's catch on fire Twitter is
a an absolute digital dumpster fire
right now
and he just makes the embodiment
of his entire existence
into God knows how much money the
American people put into that [__]
stupid rocket that they just had a rapid
unscheduled disassembly
I don't know I'd find it bunny [__] it
you know what I mean hey give him more
money let him fail some more [__] it why
not just you know what just give him the
entire United States uh budget and let
him [__] just burn that up too why
not he burned 44 billion dollars on
Twitter
who gives a [__] you know he's
destroying Tesla why [__] you know he's
smart he's intelligent he's a genius
because he's got all the money that's
what it means right rink [__] out of
here this is dumbest stupid [__] why why
in the [__] do we go to these Cycles
where the American people and humans in
general worship people who have wealth
who have stolen it from other people
you want to talk about stolen wealth
they're always like oh Texas is just
stealing rich people's money get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense most
of the people in this country the reason
why Donald Trump is [__] Rich do you
want to know do you want to know the
real reason why Donald Trump is Rich and
ain't because that [__] is smart
his dad
his dad took government money listen to
this listen to this
the United States government us the
people our country paid that
[__] to Bill to buy property we
gave him money to buy property then paid
him to build
[__] HUD housing apartment buildings
paid him money to build those
[__] then then we gave him
[__] money for the people who rent
the son of a [__] for him from him
that we paid
he didn't pay for [__]
[__] out of here with this nonsense that
rich people are smart
just because you got money doesn't mean
you're smart and doesn't mean you're all
knowing and all-powerful and by the way
you are giving that money by us you
privileged [__]
so talk about stolen [__] money
you want to talk about stolen [__]
money let's talk about stolen money that
we give
to these to this rich
the rich in this country so they can get
richer
again why don't you know we should again
I'm sure the Republicans in the house
would be happy to do this just just
appropriate every single dollar
to to Elon Musk and his businesses why
not I mean [__] it seems like it's going
really well doesn't it to you
oh [__] such a joke what a [__] joke
what are we gonna [__] just wake up
in this country and realize this stupid
[__]
and I and I know a lot of people who are
excited about the cosmos and space and
space travel are excited about this [__]
like I get it this morning you know
they're setting their their
complaints of Elon aside to celebrate
the the successes that they had this
morning look we don't have to do this
[__] we really don't
the American people can say look you
know space travel no space travel
whatever fine but we don't want him to
do it
we don't want him to do it we we're not
going to pay him any more [__] money
to do this [__] [__] him
[__] him
just like this morning
I you know I'm kind of disappointed in
the uh 10 second news cycle
you know what I mean because it's like a
10 second news cycle it really is it
really is
um someone said do I have pink eye no I
was drinking last night and it's
Thursday folks my eyes are a little
bloodshot on Thursdays don't you know
this
I I had been drinking last night maybe
it's possible
I I have fun on Wednesdays okay you'd
think it would be Fridays but I have fun
on Fridays and Saturdays too so what are
you gonna do
I don't know what the hell to tell you
so that's that's why my eyes are a
little red this morning I've been
drinking
I'm not scared to admit it you know I'm
transparent with you I would never lie
to you I wouldn't [__] you you're my
favorite turds okay I would not [__]
you're my favorite turds so yes I do
have I do have bloodshot eyes today it's
that Jagermeister yeah see everyone
knows everyone knows I love Jagermeister
and I had a friend at the barn last
night and he he bought me a couple shots
of Jager he knows I love Jaeger so he
walked to the table with jaeger laughs
oh that's how I roll that's how I roll
see they know I do karaoke on Wednesdays
to chat you guys gotta show up here
every single day every single weekday
every single week every month every year
this is gonna be important
because we're gonna hammer out these
important [__] situations like elon's
little rocket exploding in the mid-air
and then labeling at a rapid unscheduled
disassembly it [__] blew up
oh my God
oh um someone's pointing out that Vicki
H Vicki H is going on her last chemo
treatment in the chat
uh everyone everyone give her some love
we're with we're with Vicky Vicky I I
hope you get uh your your last chemo
treatment and everything goes wonderful
and swimmingly and now you continue to
get more healthy every single day we're
with you here at the [__] fan
um we we hear you we see you so everyone
give Vicki H some some love in the chat
we're not just here to have only outrage
we're here to support each other that's
right we're a family [__] we
are a [__] family even even the
haters they're part of the family you
know how it goes man you got those
cousins in your family you see him a
couple times a year you don't really
like them no they're your [__] family
what are you gonna do you know what I
mean
sad is they fly the Trump flag they were
Trump pants but you know can't help but
love that dumb son of a [__]
we all got them in our family right so
uh we love all of you all of you uh
rather you love to hate me or you love
me and the reason why you're here is for
the [__] fam and that's it in the
chat so give Vicki h
all the love in the world Vicky Vicky
has earned it she kicked Cancer's ass so
we're happy for you Vicky I again I hope
you get healthier and healthier every
single day and you're here with us here
with the [__] fam and on the Tony
Michaels podcast
for many years to come thank you Vicki h
so another situation this morning I was
talking about the 10 second news cycle
right
the 10 second news cycle apparently uh
this morning an arbitrary committee our
arbitrator someone I don't know some
kind of [__] arbitrator is
no this is [__] hilarious
you know you know the my pillow Nazi is
you know this guy that spent his whole
Fortune uh to try to prove
that Donald Trump
uh lost the election I mean that's
basically what he's proved time and time
again that Donald Trump lost the
election he had the Cyber Symposium that
was a huge face plant
he had another last year he had another
[__] Symposium down in Springfield
Missouri my own State because no one
else would have him
and that [__] that was a big huge
rake step and this year he's gonna eat
more rape but this morning oh man is he
eating rake after rake after rake these
people aren't I'm telling you they're
just they're just absolutely Olympic
rate steppers this morning in Arbiter is
forcing Mike Lindell the Mike Pella Nazi
to
to pay five million bucks to suck
okay so he he said bet me bet five
million dollars that you can't prove me
wrong that the election was stolen or
some [__] and someone [__] proved him
wrong
I gotta meet this [__] you know
what I mean I mean I you know they got
money so maybe they'll be a sponsor of
the show hell I don't know but now
here's the
hey I'm listen I'm I'm I don't have
enough uh bright you know I I I I'll
I'll take anybody in millionaires money
that wants to sponsor the show [__] yeah
we'll make an ad for you hell if you got
money out there and you want to have an
ad on the show just call me I don't give
a [__] what it is hell it could be
dildos it could be boner pills uh
whatever you want you just let me know
if you got the money we got the time
baby
and really honestly Mike Lindell if you
want to come on and do some ads uh we'll
make sure no one buys your [__] but
we'll run your ads if you want to give
us your money but this whoever the [__]
this guy is or this person or this group
is I don't know who they are I have no
idea I haven't looked into it much this
[__] just broke again the 10 second news
cycle I think I think if I would have
known about this um Mike Lindell thing
before this SpaceX rocket failed blew up
in the [__] air I almost I think I
might have put Mike Lindell on the on
the title in the thumbnail
I almost think that that 5 million bucks
that he's gonna have to pay to someone
because he's like bet bet [__] Trump
won bet [__] five million bucks
and then he has to pay us some [__] I
mean it never fails these people Time
and Time and Time and Time and Time and
Time Again are [__] digging into
their pockets because of trump it's
hilarious
this is this is this is [__]
fantastic folks I hope I really do hope
I really do hope that that whoever won
this five million bucks I hope they give
it to um some kind of election cause
like early voting or mail-in ballot some
kind of campaign for mail-in ballot
somewhere or some [__] yeah [__] yeah
hell yeah give it to the 2 000 mules I
don't know that maybe they maybe they
need to get some payment
for all that work they did during the
2020 election to steal it those 2 000
meals you know what I'm talking about
[Laughter]
oh [__]
what what a [__] joke what a [__]
joke these people are yesterday we
watched Marjorie Taylor green a clip I
never seen the clip before it was it was
just it just happened yesterday were we
alive on the air or Marjorie take the
green [__] eats rake
uh she gets silenced in a goddamn
committee and can't speak anymore
because she's a dumb ass and doesn't
know the rules and she's trying to make
clips from Fox News and every time she
tries to make [__] clips for Fox News
it [__] it backfires every [__]
time with the magonomics that she has uh
bobert's the same way with the [__]
pissing in public
it just goes on and on Matt gants with
the Chinese newspaper you remember this
he tried to quote a Chinese newspaper a
CCP newspaper a [__] propaganda rag
to a witness in Congress and they're
like look I don't believe in that
[__] [__]
it's it's [__] propaganda man
just self owns everywhere they can't
help but run face first into their own
stupidity and we should not be we should
not
be doing anything but encouraging it
that's what we should be doing is
encouraging it just keep encouraging
this stupidity and I know it denigrates
the institution of the House of
Representatives I understand that it it
if it [__] it puts our elections at
risk when Mike Lindell is just allowed
to run around the country shipping for
Donald Trump's lies spending millions of
dollars this morning five million
dollars because of his stupid [__]
lies
but [__] them [__] them let them do it I
mean Fox News is now going to pay 800
million dollars to Dominion alone who
who knows how much they'll have to pay
to smartmatic who knows how much Mike
Lindell had to pay the Dominion or
Sydney Powell the Dominion who the f I
mean there could it could be hundreds of
million dollars that Newsmax or oan pays
and that'll probably bury them for good
so [__] them let them keep trying to
sell this [__] let them trying to
keep fight democracy because I'm telling
you folks there's one thing I know in
this country and I know for damn sure
that the fabric of our country is strong
yes it's torn it's tattered I get it and
fascism is at our front door and it
wants to burn the fabric of our country
down and piss on the asses but we're not
going to let them do it
the people in this country are standing
up did you see in Iowa
at the University of Iowa Matt Walsh
goes there they wouldn't even let the
[__] leave the garage they were
throwing marbles on the floor so these
[__] fascists that went and cheered
that [__] on had to walk through
a certain entrance so they got shouted
down
you got we got to get [__] loud and
I'm happy to see that the students in
Iowa were getting loud to tell Matt
Walsh to go to [__] hell [__] him
[__] him and what he stands for that
[__] Nazi yeah I called him a Nazi
[__] him he's a Nazi you're a Nazi Matt
that's what you are and let me tell you
something in this country there's people
waking the [__] up and understanding
what you are and who you are and what
you're for and what you stand for mainly
what you stand against
and I'll tell you something standing
against diversity and equity and
inclusion is not going to work out for
your dumb ass it's just not
that's not what Jesus said and that's
not what Jesus would do dummy
so you so you best get used to it you
best get used to being shouted down
and and and if you're too [__] weak
to handle it then you need to get a
different [__] job get a different
gig man
if you don't want to be shouted down you
better stop being such a [__] Nazi
that's just the [__] plain truth of
it
if you if you want to have some sort of
tolerant existence in this country you
better get it going
that's just the way it should be
so we'll see now and and another turn of
events speaking of [__] weirdos
this morning I get on Twitter and I have
to agree with Ann Coulter what the [__]
kind of alternate universe is this
now I know Ann Coulter someone said in
the comments that she's a bad actor
right she's not a serious person I
understand this ain't Coulter is just a
[__] outrage machine right that's all
she is
but she understands what's happening she
understood long before any of these
other [__] boneheads did that Trump
was going to destroy the Republican
party and destroy the quote conservative
movement he's destroyed it they can't
then bail their fascism with
conservatism anymore are you gonna buy
that do you think the country is gonna
buy that these fascists are actually
conservatives get the [__] out of here
I mean I I've known for decades that
their their conservatism was thin veil
fascism that's all it was right just
packaged up real nice so most the
country didn't feel so icky when they
were voting for this type of [__] but
there was a line there was a line that
they couldn't cross so they could still
sell it it's [__] conservatism
not anymore and Coulter realizes that
she realized that would Trump wait way
long ago
I mean is she a scumbag [__] yeah hell
yeah she's a scumbag
but even scumbags are coming to the
around to the idea that hey this this
[__]
this Nazi [__] just is not sustainable
in this country I'll give you another
example here's another [__] example
in Missouri we talked about we had Jess
Piper on people all around the country
were [__] pissed
that Missouri was going to defund public
libraries you know who else got pissed
do you know really got pissed the people
I talked about that should be pissed
it's the rule [__] people in these
rural communities that we're gonna lose
their libraries because the state is the
only funding that some of those small
rural communities had with a library
that kept a library alive
guess what guess what the Missouri
Senate did this week voted that [__]
down they're not going to deep fund
[__] libraries in the state of
Missouri and the reason why is because
people made it not didn't give them the
ability and the space to do this [__]
and this this type of nonsense own the
libs type [__] where you use your
[__] fascism and your power in the
government to tell Americans what the
[__] they're gonna do and what they
ain't gonna do and what they want and
what they don't want
especially with their [__] tax
dollars
when you're elected by them that shit's
gonna stop
it's gonna stop
there's a there's gonna be a [__]
line somewhere and they're Crossing it
all the time we watch the Tennessee
house cross this line
expelling Justin Jones and Justin
Pearson
and not expelling the white woman Gloria
Johnson
because they went to the well and they
were loud get the [__] out of here again
loud noises are are Nazis [__]
Kryptonite and we should continue to get
loud like they did in the well in
Tennessee and like they did in Iowa and
like missourians did for the public
libraries
people in rural [__] counties in
Missouri who voted for Trump who voted
for these [__] Republicans that were
wanting to own the libs to take away the
libraries weren't gonna put up with that
[__]
they ain't gonna put up with that [__]
and in Missouri if if Jess Piper hands
her away which we're gonna have Jess
Piper back on to talk more about this
but if Jess Piper has her way and really
in some of these other red States where
there's a lot of these Republicans that
run uncontested races
they should be challenged just like Jess
Piper said that just the other day
not just not just in their general
election but in their primary
let's find Republicans because they
exist at least they can pretend to exist
that they don't want to [__] they
don't want to use their power to
legislate someone's existence or someone
out of existence or they want to focus
on genitalia what or checking checking
children's genitalia at sporting events
or what [__] bathrooms people are
going in Jesus Christ no one gives a
[__] about that
they don't people don't give two shits
and if you do give two shits you're a
[__] bigot that's right you're a
[__] big and you just you just don't
got your head on straight like old
Dustin in the chat here's a hero every
day saying stupid [__] he's the [__]
Trump manga copy machine man
every day same [__] just like fake game
used to be [__] Dustin probably is old
fake Gabe
but that's the way we live
and and we have to do something about it
we have to do something about it and how
we do it is we [__] engage in our
democracy that's how we do it
we engage
you get loud again I've got one
microphone but you've got thousands
thousands of microphones that you can
use
something you could use your feet you
could use your phone hell you could
write letters send postcards for this
next upcoming election
there's all kinds of stuff that you can
do with the talents that you have to
help defend your democracy it's true
it's true
but this is what we're up against
it's Mike Lindell
Elon Musk
Ron DeSantis have you seen oh my God
Rhonda Santos is such a [__] failure
this is the best they got to run like
he's gonna be a superstar right he's
gonna be a [__] Superstar oh my God
he's going to be the president United
States he's going to turn America into
Florida what the [__]
dude can't even dude can't get Disney
off his mind
this this [__] guy is so obsessed
with his own sexual orientation I think
that he can't stop obsessing about
Disney's sexual orientation or some dumb
[__] I don't know what the hell he's
doing
Bob Iger is gonna [__] wad Ron
DeSantis up and toss him in the garbage
we talked about it on Tuesday with Texas
Paul there's no way Ron DeSantis is
going to win any kind of battle with
Disney or Bob Iger number one Ron
DeSantis has limited power as the
governor and he only has a limited time
to do it so good luck to you you [__]
[__]
and he went crawling he went crawling to
DC and Trump won folks I'm telling you
I've been telling you since [__]
January a lot of people won't [__]
listen to me Rhonda santis will not win
in the primary he's probably not even
going to run
yeah I told you back in [__] December
and January Trump is going to be the
nominee I've been saying it for months
and months and months over and over
every [__] day here
I got all the [__] recordings to
prove it and do whatever the hell you
want but I'm telling you Trump's gonna
be the nominee and Ronda santis had his
chance to announce his run for for
president and it was the week that Trump
got indicted on 34 felonies in the state
of New York that was his opportunity
it's gone it's lost Trump got 60 some
[__] endorsements from Republican
Congressman the other day Rhonda santis
didn't help him it didn't help people in
the state his State of Florida when
they're underwater flooding where'd that
[__] do he flew to D.C to beg
people to give him endorsements when
he's not even really actually running
for president of the United States
you know how many he got two
two [__]
he got two [__] to endorse him
he's [__]
he's completely 100 [__] his window
closed it's gone just go back to Florida
put on your little [__] white rain
boots Ron and go down to [__] Fort
Lauderdale and help those [__] people
out
and stop being such a goddamn Nazi
maybe that'll help
I don't know stop being a bigot that
might [__] help
you run a [__] national campaign
because people out here
in the rest of the country maybe
Florida's a little different but in the
rest of the country you gotta put up
with your nonsense try and take away
women's rights to Health Care
trying to [__] get rid of books burn
books because it's got the statue of
David in it and you think that's
pornography Banning math because it oh
my God the MacBook has the word CRT in
it
not being able to say the word gay
because it hurts your [__] feelings
quit being such goddamn [__] no one
gives a [__] about other people's
business they really don't they don't
give a [__]
Americans just want to live their own
[__] lives they don't want to go
broke because of a medical bill they
don't want to have to pay so much
Goddamn money when they have their one
or two kids go to [__] daycare so we
should help them get it get their kids
in school at three instead of five we
don't want [__] children going
goddamn hungry in schools because their
parents can't make ends meet and buy
them a school lunch
we don't want people to be saddled for
their entire [__] lines with college
debt it's dumb it's stupid let's educate
the country and let's move forward we
want people to make a decent [__]
wage and I'm not talking about being
wealthy I'm talking about just just
having a roof over your head maybe be
able to buy a [__] house
maybe be able to afford to live in the
community that you want to live in
[__] out of here man Americans aren't
[__] greedy
it's these fascists who are greedy and
they're greedy with what you want
what they want to tell you to do
they always want to tell you what you
can and can't do and who you can and
can't be who you can't and can't love
who you can [__]
what you can smoke what you can eat what
you can drink
what religion you can have what gods you
can [__] pray to [__] out of here
with that nonsense America doesn't
believe that [__]
to our to our rotten little core we
don't believe in that [__] you
telling us what we can and can't do what
books we can read
[__] out of here
enough of that [__]
let's kick them to the curb just like
whoever this was that
I'm sorry Mike Lindell has to pay five
million bucks because he bet
this is fantastic what a great day the
rocket explodes in midair and so does
Mike Lindell everyone stick around don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it's 4 20.
[Music]
oh boy you know it's hat week two here
at the Tony Michaels podcast
get your [__] hats while they're hot
you get 10 off that's right 10 off of
[__] em hat just use
the promo code hat week 10 that's hat
week one zero on the hat store here's
how you find the hat store paying
attention go to the Tony michaels.com
that's
thetonymichaels.com click the [__] em
hat store link you scroll down a bit
you'll find it or you can go to
hats.dtonymichaels.com that's hats dot
the tonymichaels.com and you just use
the promo code hat week 10 that's hat
week one zero to get your [__] em hats
now if you're like Loki and you're
waiting for your beanies which they're
going to be there this afternoon I'm
gonna put them in there this afternoon
wait till then you'll get 10 off
your beanie your [__] beanie this
afternoon I'll probably post it on
social media and patreon and I'll just
post it around once I get the listing up
and it's active and you can go purchase
one
go go to the Tony michaels.com
click the hat store link you can get you
a ball cap like I got here there's
trucker hats
now they're snapbacks these are there's
some fitted hats [__] them hats in this
afternoon there will be beanies if you
want a [__] them beanie so make sure to
go to the Tony michaels.com click the
hat store link use the promo code hat
week 10 that's hat week one zero and
you'll get ten percent off your entire
hat order
we got a few minutes before Gabe Sanchez
joins us you know I liked yesterday we
did the shoot the [__] let's do [__]
this [__] again today who wants to shoot
the [__]
um here we go Brandi Brandy asked a
question here beanies what now I need
more hands yeah so we're we're gonna
we're gonna have beanies uh here's what
here's what happened we had the patreon
party last Sunday
um I told some stories I talked to some
some Patron members on Zoom uh it was
great we had a lot of fun I think we
were doing it for like almost three
hours I think
seeing the problem was I couldn't figure
out the zoom zoom's [__] complicated
it's clunky [__] soon what are you gonna
do though you gotta use technology to
get these uh these situations to work
for like the patreon party so I use zoom
I'm not used to it took me a bit
it took me a bit to get um the the
karaoke up so we sang Cario I sang
karaoke and then um I told some stories
answered some questions that everyone
had and one of the questions that Loki
had was he wanted to know if he could
get a [__] beanie because he likes
beanies but he wants to [__] beanie
so I'm like yeah sure we'll put a
[__] beanie so this afternoon I
should have the [__] beanies up in
the store so you'll be able to go to the
um hat store and get you a beanie get
you a beanie
[Music]
someone said is that hat foil lined I
need I need to foil
look listen I don't sell any tin foil
hats but honestly if you guys wanted tin
foil [__] em hats I I would put them in
the store I'd put them a lot of people
have been sending me links for like
whistles too they want the [__] the
[__] whistles
and it's what I keep seeing is everyone
wants [__] whistles so I'm gonna try
to see we'll work over the next few
weeks to try to get um the [__]
whistle we're working on some new stuff
right now
so um we're working on some new art for
the show so um we're gonna keep the same
logo like we have here
but we're gonna change the um the
podcast cover uh or change how it looks
change some of the art we're gonna
change some stuff around a bit so you
guys are going to see some new some new
stuff happening just an update no big
deal we're just making making some
upgrades you know level up leveling up
our our look here so we'll be doing that
um did I miss Tony's bleed the SpaceX
special destruction yes that's the first
thing I did was celebrate uh elon's
explosion this morning Up in Smoke oh
let's see
what else do we get do we got any more
uh questions we're shooting the [__]
here so if you get questions put them in
the um put them in the chat here
and I'll try to see if I can get to them
uh let's see
anybody got a question anybody got a
question
Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining us
he's just he's just a bit behind oh
Linda says Tony you need cowboy hats
I I mean damn
there's there's a lot of things I gotta
have I wouldn't mind you know what maybe
I should at least make a [__] hat for
me Gabe and Texas Paul where we could
wear cowboy hats on Tuesdays right maybe
that's what we should do at least just
make them for us
um maybe I don't know I don't know
um someone asked Kim P says is it true
bongino
lost his job
um I know he's trending on Twitter let's
take a look let's take a look I seen he
was trending but I didn't um
I didn't I didn't see breaking news oh
it's his contributorship at Fox
so Fox News probably isn't renewing
their contract with Dan bongino
um to to be a contributor or it's
possible
it's possible they're saying that Fox
fired him I don't I don't know he just
doesn't get very good ratings I guess
because he's a [__] idiot that's
probably why Dan you're a [__]
dumbass that's probably why Fox fired
you you know what you should do you know
you should do not be such an [__]
that's that's what Dan should do he
should just not be such a [__]
[__] and he would keep his job right
I mean that's what most people would do
he's still got his show though so um
he's not he's not gonna lose his show
he's just not gonna be on [__]
Fox News doing his [__] over there
and and then probably the reason why is
because of some of these uh this
Dominion lawsuit is they can't afford
these [__] anymore
they probably can't afford to pay these
some [__] anymore
so they're gonna have to [__] cut fat
right that's what they're gonna have to
do
just gonna have to cut fat off of these
uh contributors that way they can afford
the 800 million dollars that they gotta
pay dominion and they're not out of the
woods yet smart manic is going to assume
too and the bar is set see that's the
exciting thing about
um what Dominion did with the 800
million because really if you think
about it that's how much the lies are
worth right to Dominion
and really even the smartmatics so the
defamation lies that
um
that
um oan Newsmax Fox News Sydney Powell
Michael and Dell all these [__]
boneheads he thought it was a good idea
to defame these companies with their
outright wise because their [__]
snowflake feelings got hurt that Trump
lost and they have to cover for him with
more lies
that's how much it's worth
so I mean
when Dominion goes to settle with oan
and Newsmax you think you think Dominion
is going to be like well you know
Fox News gave us 800 but we'll just set
them for a couple million with you [__]
no
starts it starts at least 800 million
right I mean I think so I think that the
suit against new smacks is bigger than
the one against Fox News let's see do we
have any met did it did
Everyone likes this phrase
let them eat rake what a great one
what a great one and it was developed
here right in the [__] fan
so I'm happy that we have the phrase let
them eat rake like bongino this morning
Mike Lindell Elon Musk
Marjorie Taylor green yesterday was
eating rake
in the [__] house hearing so and I'm
sure by the time we get to the end of
the show we'll show a few more clips of
these people absolutely uh eating rake
oh that what else we got we're gonna
we're gonna watch the video of elon's
Rocket uh having a rapid unscheduled
disassembly it's exploded man that's
what it's called it's exploded
what else do we got you guys got any
more questions yeah yesterday we showed
uh Jane Jane has it here Dan Goldman uh
was the one one of the ones that
real yeah him and and Benny Thompson are
the ones that really made sure that uh
Marjorie Taylor green got a real good
taste of that rake handle
she loves the taste of that handle on
the end of The Rake loves it uh oh uh
underdoggy he's got a question Tony I
like your hairstyle what kind of hair
treatment do you use hair treatment like
product oh well I mean I use like a
pomade
why it's not Dapper Dan
[Laughter]
I'm not a Dapper Dan man you ever seen
them Oh Brother Where Art Thou when he
goes into the the General Store and he's
trying to get to Pomade I forget the one
they've got and but he wants Dapper Dan
he's a Dapper Dan man
uh so but yeah it's um it's Paul me just
pomade
just to just a a heavy hold High shine I
like the high shine
um
yeah Paul asked do you are Gabe dabble
in any hip-hop parody or otherwise no
Paul I I mean
I can sing country but that's that's
about it I don't know if Gabe can rap
I don't know
I don't know he wouldn't sing the other
night he says he can sing but he
wouldn't do it he wouldn't do it so
maybe he he will eventually when we get
on that maybe when he gets on the show
here he should be here soon and when he
gets on the show here
when
when are The Rake shirts coming God damn
um I I guess after the beanies and the
whistles we'll get the let them meet
rake shirts I don't know
you guys like the um I got to lock him
up banners
there in the merch store if you go to
store that detoni michaels.com I've got
lock them up
and shirts there but maybe we should do
the let them eat rake
man
what else do we get what else do we have
here today any other questions that you
got for me it can be politics it doesn't
have to be politics we're just shooting
the [__] here today
oh Dustin oh you poor little guy
your poor little guy Tony is a creepy
little man hey Dustin you're the one who
comes here every day and puts in weird
[__] in the chat man
you're the you're the one who is
obsessed with me friend
do your friends know that do your
friends know that you come watch me
every day
he he he excites me he gets me so
excited I'm typing in messages
as fast as I can on Facebook
you're the weirdo dude you're the weirdo
I know you got an obsession with me I
get it a lot of people do some people
love me some people love to hate me but
you yours is special so keep coming
Dustin keep coming oh
[Music]
secession referendum on the 2023 ballot
Is that real super Saint says Tony's
Texas secession referendum I you know I
I'm not opposed to Texas knowing if they
if their citizenry would like to leave
I mean why wouldn't they want to know
that now I mean here's the thing here's
the thing is that yes
yes they they would not want to leave no
one they're not going to secede from the
union this is really stupid [__] so I
mean if that's real if they're really
gonna put a referendum on the ballot I'm
for that yeah for sure fine whatever
whatever they want to do
I'm for everyone's Liberty and I think
we should have more democracy democracy
is good
it's not bad
um super Saint says Dustin jelly bee
because Tony sexy AF that might be it
may be what he's jealous of maybe it's
he can't grow a beard and I can that
could be it it's manhood right he's
really he's obsessed with my beard and
how I can grow and he can
let's see what else do we have
no no no no
of course you do of course you tell your
friends about your obsession with me I
know I get it man I understand it
I I understand that you tell your
friends
that you come and you're you're creepy
in the chat and [__] and you say weird
stuff you're like huh I totally own this
guy watch him two hours every day
because I don't have a job
you know I live in my mom's basement so
I can watch him every day and I can I
control him it's it's really exciting
you know most dust and most people most
people in the chat are at work and
they're sneaking in the chat right
they're sneaking in the chat I'm telling
you they're either retired or they're
sneaking in the chat because most the
audience they have jobs and [__]
they have jobs and [__]
and just ask them in the chat I'm
telling you these people are watching
like with their earbuds and [__] at
their desk sneaking the [__] you're just
you're just like out there
bragging about how you're creepy
Let's see we got any more questions
um why hasn't the FCC pulled Fox News
license to broadcast because they won't
they're a cable company
yeah again
so you have to understand something
right like
um a lot of liberals and a lot of the
left want to for Fox News to be off the
air which I mean I'm not opposed to Fox
News not existing but we we as a society
can't go well you can't exist because we
don't like you because if we do that to
them they can do that to us do you
understand that's the problem with doing
that right so what we have to do is we
have to be louder our arguments are way
better than theirs folks our arguments
sell way better than theirs now
generally speaking the left and
Democrats are horrible at selling their
ideas that's why you come here every
single day
because I don't make it [__]
complicated to sell to sell an idea that
the American people want right
I don't make it [__] complicated I
don't I don't require you to go read
[__] encyclopedia's worth of data and
polls to understand that Americans don't
want to go broke because of a medical
bill right it's not [__] complicated
and you don't have to use scary stupid
words to describe that you just say we
don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill most most people in America
understands that health care costs money
right like if you go to the doctor you
get a prescription drug you understand
that you're gonna have to pay a little
bit
but people who number one don't have the
money to afford it should still be able
to get their prescription drugs and
their doctor's visits even if they can't
afford it we're rich enough elon's got
enough [__] money Jesus Christ he
burnt 44 billion dollars buying Twitter
and he burned up a rocket this morning
and you're going to try to convince us
that we ain't got enough money to give
people [__] insulin in this country
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense yeah that's the dumbest [__]
I've ever heard in my life if we can
spend money on elon's [__] failed
rocket and Elon can [__] spend 44
billion dollars to destroy Twitter then
he can afford some [__] taxes
that's just the longer the short of it
and every billionaire like him can
afford it too [__] you get the [__] out
of here you can't convince American
people that that's not true right those
aren't hard ideas to sell
now the only thing that we have to do
with Fox news is we have to be louder
we have to be that's why yelling
screaming to the microphone every day
I'm the outrage machine on the left or
the rushland ball the laughter I mean
I've been called a lot of things
and I'm gonna be called a lot more and a
lot worse and I don't give a [__] that's
that's my job that's that's where I'm at
that's the space that I exist in I
understand it I get it I'm kind of the
rodeo clown if you want to call it of
the left I get that
but it's to form a national narrative
and and you know like Dustin I give
Dustin [__] but Dustin he literally is
telling his friends his [__] brain
dead ass friends his delusional friends
that have been [__] brainwashed and
mind [__] into this stupid [__] on
the libs as if liberalism is [__] bad
and fascism good right they've been
[__] mind [__] into this stupid
[__] white supremacy the institution of
white supremacy has done a hell of a job
on white people in this country and even
bled out past white people on the on the
people of color
white supremacy the institution of white
supremacy I'm not talking about just
like the KKK wearing hoods and [__] I'm
talking about institutional white
supremacy right
but here's the thing if Dustin comes
every day and he gets a hundred of his
friends his dumb [__] friends which I
doubt doesn't has a hundred friends
Dustin maybe you got 100 friends maybe I
mean you might have 10 20. yeah best but
hey that's okay because Dustin gets
three or four
maybe maybe one of his friends to come
and watch and then that maybe that that
guy has two or three friends they come
watch and then they come watch and they
come watch and they come and listen
don't you see how that could perpetuate
right
that's how you move the [__] needle
Democrats and liberals in general don't
understand that they don't get how to
move the needle they look at they look
at like Rush Limbaugh and right right
wing talk radio and they're like oh it's
so bad and we should do the opposite of
that no what are you talking about
what do you you say the opposite but you
do the thing they're doing it worked we
got Trump you stupid bastards what do
you what do you think where do you think
Trump came from you think Trump just
[__] was a fart out of thin air no it
was [__] decades and decades and
Decades of the right wing
thin baling conservatism our fascism up
as conservatism and selling it on right
wing talk radio and Fox News okay and
it's the way they did it and how they
did it and how they kept people's
attention the whole goddamn time that's
how it works that's how it [__] I'd hate
to be so transparent about it but that's
how it [__] works
I mean the reason why a lot of you come
here and watch every day is number one
the [__] fam is the best chat fam in
the goddamn Universe you I I dare you to
find a better one go [__] find it
good luck
number two we give good support here at
the at the [__] fam in the chat
it's it's about democracy
it's about Liberty it's about making
sure that everyone has equal [__]
rights and equality in this country now
it isn't perfect we know democracy isn't
perfect
it's not designed to be perfect that's
kind of the point it's because we got to
work our asses off to do these things
because once we work our asses to do off
to do these things it's harder for them
to take it away from us
but the other thing about this show that
I know the reason why you come and watch
is because how I do this
did you know I I know I've told you this
before I designed this show after right
wing talk radio that's why it sound
that's why people call me the Russian
ball the left because it sounds like his
show it's the same [__] format almost
I designed it to sound like that but I'm
saying the opposite [__] I'm saying the
[__] truth pro-democracy propaganda
if you want to call it that
so we can't we can't just get rid of Fox
News because if we get rid of Fox News
they can get rid of me they can get rid
of anyone else
when they take power when they had the
reins and the opportunity to do it what
we do to get rid of Fox News is unmind
[__] all these people
yes it's gonna take a long time folks
it's it's hard work isn't done in a day
okay and the hard work of democracy
definitely isn't done in a lifetime
we've been working on this democracy for
[__] hundreds of years
and democracy has been around for
thousands and we're still not perfecting
it yet
and I don't know that we ever will have
a perfect Republic
but it's worth every single [__]
every single ounce of blood and sweat
for that
chance of equity inequality for everyone
and the reason why I try to amplify my
voice every single day is because of my
personal experience
of knowing what people like Dustin think
and where he comes from
because I know my experience is that
folks I get it
and I try I try to understand that I try
to listen to others experience
because I believe that everyone's
experience everyone's is important it is
important to our nation
and we can't discount one over the other
and just because someone was mind [__]
by the institution of white supremacy or
Fox News now I'm not making excuses
these people need to be held accountable
they need to be mocked
that is the appropriate way to handle
them
well when they change their minds
when the when the when the Paradigm of
society shifts again and it will trust
me it will
then we will know why Fox News shouldn't
exist as a society and no one will watch
that garbage no one will give it [__]
time a day DirecTV cable companies
aren't going to give it a percentage of
its [__] subscription anymore because
it's garbage and no one wants that [__]
and no one wants to hear the [__]
lies anymore but right now right now
we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life and folks
these people want to be lied to you like
Dustin and his buddies that come watch
this they want to be lied to
they want to be heard what they want to
hear
because it hurts their sensitive
privilege
to hear the truth about what history is
and about what [__] is now they just
it's too much for them they're too
sensitive they're too snow flaky they're
[__] ass [__] they can't handle it
they can't but Dustin comes here every
day and his buddies come here every day
so they can at least handle my my style
of Truth and eventually eventually even
as thick-headed as Dustin is it might
sink in maybe an ID or two just an ID or
two
and on and on and on they'll go and
we'll chip away and chip away and Chip
it away because it's worth it
I know a lot of people don't like Dustin
I know a lot of people or people like
Dustin
but if Dustin changed his mind tomorrow
and he legitimately said you know what I
was [__] wrong and he came here and
said it you'd welcome him
you'd welcome him
so let's not give up on our citizens
let's not give up on our countrymen just
because places like Fox News and the
right wing talk radio like Dan bongino
and Mike Lindell and all these other
[__] bio ass fascists have mind
[__] these people
we shouldn't just count them out what we
need to do to get rid of Fox News is not
is not again cancel them out of
existence
let's use our democracy let's use our
capitalism to get rid of those
[__] because I don't know if
you noticed Fox News is like oh First
Amendment First Amendment
and they had to pay 800 800 million
dollars because of their dumbass First
Amendment statements because there's one
thing that Fox News understands because
it is about their first amendment folks
I'm not doubting that at all
not one bit
Fox News has the right to say whatever
the [__] they want whatever lies they
want to sell
but the thing they don't have the right
to
is the consequences of that speech
the consequences so let's make them pay
the [__] consequences we do not have
to regulate them or or [__] get the
or just snap our fingers and they're
gone folks oan's done I don't know if
you know this ohan's [__] done and
the reason why is because oan is trash
and garbage and Direct TV and every
other provider is like yeah we're not
putting you on our [__] platform [__]
that [__] no one's gonna buy our [__] if
you're on there because you're a goddamn
dumpster fire you're bad for business
that's that's capitalism
that's because you vote with your
[__] money
it's your vote it's your vote with your
money
but we have to pair our vote with our
money with our microphones and that's
most important someone's got their
microphone on it looks like maybe we'll
see if he's got his microphone on Gabe
Sanchez yeah
good job good job
now where that's taken some questions
from the audience session oh yeah yeah
I'm just talking about Fox News there so
I didn't have propaganda yeah what was
it 20 minute rant something like that on
Fox News so I'm like I mean I I feel
like you can always do a 20-minute run
yeah [__] yeah man hails to the yeah I
mean I could do two hours on Fox News
alone
they they are um
how do you say it [__] uh yeah they're
just I mean you know that's a lot of
money man 800 million bucks I mean it's
it's not gonna it's not gonna like phase
them like immediately right and Rupert
Murdoch can [__] 800 million dollars
right yeah yeah so right I mean it's not
but I mean it's it look I know a lot of
like I I too was in the camp and I'm
still in the camp of like yo I want to
see this [__] right I want to see the
documents I want to see the testimony I
want to see them have to answer these
questions specifically the Fox News
hosts that knew that they were pushing
right lies I mean everyone wants to see
the truth but you know but again like we
talked about yesterday 2.7 billion
dollar smartmatic Dominion has you know
uh set the bar I think it was I think it
was Katie Katie Fang who said it uh I
saw it on Instagram she was like
Dominion crawled so smart Mata could run
right and that's really what it is right
now because now we have the bar that's
set we say okay the minimum
is 787 million
and 500 000. and now smartmatic knows
going in like great we know exactly what
what the minimum is for a 1.6 billion
dollar lawsuit now we're 2.7 so maybe we
get another billion in there maybe we
say you know [__] it we'll go to court
like you know maybe for smartmatic it's
less on like that we're you know we
don't need the money we're willing just
to push you out there to expose the lies
and put in the public
um you know it's just one of those
things where I'm like
it's all coming like it's all coming
back you know we've got Mike Lindell
that shit's coming back to him today
yeah man I I totally I I text you I was
like this 10 second new cycle man yeah
yeah it really [__] me this morning
because I put the Elon thing we put the
Elon thing and it's like yeah well you
know it's like you're like send it out
as soon as I send it out I've seen the
Mike Lindell so I'm like God damn it man
yeah and it's gonna and it's gonna it's
gonna like rap in the news cycle so we
won't be able to come back to it
tomorrow probably yeah someone someone
on Twitch is asking what is the show
about are you talking about this show
what the [__] I don't know stick around
you'll [__] find out
hide and watch hiding watch over there
on Twitch I guess I got some more um
some comments here
um ones from KIRO uh there's the Mexican
hunk of I told you people we changed the
name it's chips and giggles and Giggles
don't wear it out
ah he's gonna regret he ever [__]
said yeah I know it'd be like 20 years
from now he's gonna be I'm still trying
to think of what my my chemistry teacher
told me you still haven't thought of it
no I couldn't you need to get high today
I know are you gonna die today for 4 20.
later today later
I gotta do I got meetings and I gotta
what was that I gotta film and you know
me show up drunk and high at meetings
yeah yeah seriously I think you told
that story one time on here yeah yeah I
showed up wasted on Margaritas too and
then just turned off the camera turned
off the sound yeah because I had to go
[__] out for a minute I had to go puke
it was an important meeting too like it
was a really important meeting and
Gabe's like hey are you okay over there
he's like texting me I'm like wait wait
wait wait hold on somebody says uh is
this a joke I'm not Mexican
I was not born in Mexico you don't have
to be born in Mexico to be Mexican I
don't think I mean I don't know I
thought first generation was good enough
right well you know born there right
well I'll go [__] myself yeah why don't
you why don't you just go [__] yourself
chips and Giggles I gotta I've got
another question no that's not a joke
I'm not Mexican because I wasn't born in
Mexico what what I don't think I mean
you're American I know you're
Mexican-American I'm American yeah I
mean you consider yourself
Mexican-American or a big step fan here
it says you're I don't agree you're
American right yeah but yeah I'm I mean
I was I was born in America and yes I'm
American but I still also consider
myself Mexican
like I'm sure if you want to if you here
if you wanna split hairs you want to
split hairs but call myself
Mexican-American right right but I I you
know like I don't
okay because your entire family like
your dad's side is yeah yeah
I was literally just there visiting
family in Mexico
anyone anyone who who is who is in your
in your family that is on the Mexican
side they're all from yeah I think that
they would I think that they would be
would they consider you Mexican
yeah like you're real I could when you
go to Mexico right yeah yeah even though
even though your mom's white she's she's
from America if you go to Mexico they
consider you Mexican right yeah yeah but
I mean we talked about it on the show
where like you know when you were
growing up
some some of the Mexican Community you
weren't Mexican enough and the white
Community
that's a challenge yeah that's a
challenge and that exists in both places
in America and also in Mexico uh but if
I'm with my family it's not like oh
check out that Gringo man it's like it's
like there is Gabe is our family he's
Mexican
Giggles look at chips and Giggles over
there also if someone if someone needs
me to verify like do I have a Mexican ID
no I don't but also I am uh
uh because I don't know what's going on
a Mexican citizen maybe is what big
Steph is saying yeah yeah however
however I'm I thought can you have dual
citizenship yeah yeah and that's
actually something I'm working on oh
really yeah yeah so did your does your
dad have dual citizenship or is he just
citizen of Mexico he's just a citizen of
Mexico okay I got you uh so I'm I'm
actually this year I'm working on
becoming a dual citizen that's pretty
good so what what is what is so when you
if you become a dual citizen what what
what kind of benefits do you get being I
can get the [__] out of this country as
soon as I want
ain't that a [__] when you're
going when you're like oh [__] I'm going
across the border the other direction
when Republicans like oh they're all
coming here to take our jobs right like
I want to go live on the beach in Mexico
that sounds yeah yeah so that's the plan
uh but what and it doesn't I don't if I
remember correctly like the actual
you know what here's the thing if you
moved to a certain part of Mexico you'll
be in my time zone
if I yeah yes two hours if I move to
Mexico City [__] be able to
sleep in yeah [__] be able to
sleep in God damn she should be more
full is that what you want to do is go
to Mexico City and live there uh not
right now
maybe later yeah yeah it would be like
every time I go back as I've been going
back more and more recently yeah I'm
like but also there's this whole there's
a whole side of the culture now of like
during the pandemic a lot of people move
down to to Mexico because it was it was
not as expensive right right and and
it's the same issue that Portugal is
experiencing right now where people were
moving to Portugal there's a bunch of
expats that are in Portugal and a bunch
of people the Portuguese who are there
are getting upset because they're
causing the prices to go up the
affordability for housing is going like
it's all of this stuff is changing the
same thing has happened in Mexico City
as well and you know it's a whole thing
there's like certification which is a
double-edged sword
um but there's a bunch of people who own
properties and the cost of living has
gone up and the people who live there in
the city had to be pushed out you know
it's I mean
we see it in every every country that
happens yeah well and it's really I mean
it's in every state too right in the
state of Missouri because like where I
live it's one of the lowest cost of
livings in the entire country yeah that
might be nice like well like literally
I'm sure my house
cost about half of what your one bedroom
apartment cost probably literally yeah
and and my entire family's able to live
here and have some space right yeah and
we've got like extra rooms like I've got
you know weight room in the gym I'm
sleeping in my dogs man it's [__]
crazy
you know you know did she kick you out
of bed does that one happen is that why
you're sleeping with the dogs
okay so here's another question we were
on Fox News someone said how about rsbn
um I I actually don't know if I
understand is actually being insane yeah
I don't I don't think it's just news Max
and Fox News right and then the
individual parties but I don't think
rsbn is on there I for somehow rsbn got
well because rsbn the one thing that
rsvn doesn't do is pretend that it's not
con that it's not commentary like Fox
News they'll pretend that their
commentary is news
um Newsmax and oam the same way they're
trying to pretend that they're kind of
like we don't pretend that our
commentary is [__] news here right
yeah yeah we're commentating on the news
but we're not and and we we'll we'll
cover things live as they're happening
to give you commentary on those things
but we're not pretending that somehow
yeah you know we're like we're like
Tucker Carlton in the sense that uh
we are an entertainment show right and
you have to be so gullible to no but
yeah no I don't but I mean in some
reality we're not yeah yeah we're we're
commentating on the news right but it's
but we're not reporting yeah I'm not a
journalist yeah I'm not you know I'm not
every you know 5 p.m 6 p.m 10 p.m 11 p.m
news not reporting and and holding me
accountable I mean I think people should
hold this accountable but I mean like
holding us accountable to like the
general population to be like oh what
they're saying is
this bad thing which is what happened
with Fox News a way in the Newsmax and I
looked
I looked on rsbn and I can't find
anything yeah I don't think it means I
think they somehow save themselves I
don't know what they did and what they
didn't do well again reporting on this
but again there's there's probably not
much evidence that that they were
outright um you know they're gonna be
the only [__] one left man
well you know rsbn's one of the worst of
them though right I know I mean like
that reality
I honestly almost like well if Newsmax
and Owen gets [__] you don't you don't
think Fox and you survives this I mean
to some form no no Fox News will survive
this I mean I'm really curious he may be
broke for they may be broke yeah yeah
because again like as I was saying on
the show yesterday at the end of 2022
they had 4.1 billion in cash in cash
equivalents so there's a reason why they
didn't want to go to court because they
were on the hook for 1.6 billion for the
lawsuit now the jury could come back and
say you know what for everything you
guys did and for all the people that
were [__] brainwashed and crazy and
the Insurrection and all this stuff you
have to consider the possibility not
that
we don't know what happened but there's
the possibility that the jury could come
back and be like oh you guys owe them
three billion dollars right which would
be crazy and I don't I wouldn't imagine
that would happen
and then it would probably go and get
appealed and there would be some lower
amount and who knows what they would end
up paying
but uh but the reason they paid the
nearly 800 million is because they
looked at and they're like look
it's just better to call it a loss here
because I mean even before even going in
I don't know if people know this but
there was the evidence they had
submitted is they were they were
submitting clips of The Simpsons
did you know that what yeah let me let
me find the Tweet because it was from uh
so so why you're looking for that Scott
Perkins asked is rsbn bannon's Channel
or is it different rsbn does carry
bannon's podcast
um there's other Chan like Michael and
Dells
um whatever is it Frank speech is that
what yeah Frank speech Frank speech.com
frenchbeach.com they they carry bannon's
show as well so you gotta remember like
like um like shows like ours we're gonna
go out and be on a network like we're
not gonna We're Not Gonna pin ourselves
where it's like I know this is a really
big exclusive deal where we can only
broadcast our show on one network
yeah like we we want to be able to
Syndicate in other words sort of it's a
little different in the world that we
live in now with podcasts as opposed to
radio because you have the internet but
but uh band and Bannon rsbn has won one
of the networks as it were that actually
holds
um bannon's bannon's show yeah um but
again you're not going to get rid of
Bannon either even if you get rid of
rsbn and Newsmax and Ohan he's going to
be able to [__] I mean look at Alex
Jones [__] he's doing everything
he can not to pay that billion dollars
or close to a billion dollars that he
owes the Sandy Hook families that
[__] is still yelling and
screaming into a microphone and he'll
continue to because that that's that's
what people don't understand about the
freedom of speech even liberals and
laughs sometimes they don't understand
that it's not yes you have the right to
say whatever the [__] you want now
sometimes it isn't freedom of speech
like if you're acting on hate speech or
you're yelling the great example is fire
in a crowded theater right
um but there it doesn't mean that you
don't have consequences of your speech
whatever you're saying has [__]
consequences like my speech here almost
every day has consequences of democracy
and people engaging in their democracy
that's consequence I'm and I'm willing
to live with the other consequences for
that one in particular so yeah there's
consequences for your speech
um what's the link that you sent me here
all right so the first one is it's from
Ed and he was summarizing what was done
and the second one is the actual article
itself
so this is this is on on April 18th this
is what they were leading they were
going in
before they before before they settled
and agreed to nearly 800 million dollars
in this lawsuit this is what they were
submitting and this is not a joke
submitting this Fox News this is Fox
News their legal team was submitting
this
that's evidence
so Ed let me read what Ed said breaking
no joke Fox News has just unveiled some
of their exhibits for the Dominion trial
they include four separate clips from a
hit TV show series The Simpsons the the
one you're thinking of like Bart Simpson
that's the one the cartoon yep right the
four episodes all show Homer Simpson
voting in presidential elections oh my
are you [__] kidding me so one of
them is Homer Simpson votes for Obama
one of them is Homer votes for Romney
um one of them is where Putin tries to
convince Homer to vote for Donald Trump
and then the fourth one is Homer is
indecisive when going and voting for
Biden or Trump yeah this is [__] real
does Fox News really think jury's this
is so why is this an exhibit
like what do they think this proves uh I
I look okay so according to this article
I was reading it says Fox News suggested
on Tuesday uh April 18th that it would
defend itself against defamation claims
by showing a jury partial episodes of
The Simpsons
um it includes four clips and three of
the Clips Homer Simpson is shown to be
presidential is considering a
presidential candidate uh other than
Donald Trump a fourth clip shows
Vladimir Putin uh voting for Trump
uh it doesn't make any sense man like I
like this is the this is this is the
reason well so so here was one one of
their main
um
arguments they're anchors for their
arguments I should say
so they what what Fox News was trying to
say which it didn't seem like the court
was buying it but it didn't matter what
the court was buying it matters what the
jury would have bought right and they
actually seeded 12 jurors and I think
they actually selected 12
um backup jurors by the time they I
think they had to hold oh yeah you got
you gotta have you got to have backups
well I know but I mean they had them
seated by the time they settled right
right yeah like the judge wouldn't let
them take any more time the judge is
like no we're gonna get the [__] jury
and then if you come to an agreement
then fine but we're going to move ahead
with this thing because the judge was
getting impatient the judge was not
going to wait on these [__] to
work this out and the reason why the
judge is smart to do that is because the
judge is like look if you either come to
an agreement or you don't right we're in
[__] Court here you you're you
brought the litigation to this point
either [__] or get off the pot now one
of their arguments was is that what Fox
News was doing was just reporting what
Donald Trump was saying because Donald
Trump was the president of time and he
was saying all these [__] lies the
problem comes when Fox News was when
they were reporting what he was saying
wasn't saying that's a [__] lie yeah
because they can't say well Dominion
this Dominion that dominionist Dominion
that and defame them without saying
telling their viewers even though that's
a lie that's what Donald Trump is saying
because other networks and other press
coverage they were because they didn't
want to get caught in this situation
with defamation
they didn't they wanted to make sure
they said
yes he's saying this but it's [__]
untrue right there's no there's no fact
in this Hugo Chavez did not [__]
compel Dominion out of from his grave
right to change the votes or some [__]
so the only thing I can think of that
why they would use these clips of Homer
is that maybe they
maybe Fox News wanted to argue that they
you know it was entertainment right Fox
was entertainment you know and it was
even The Simpsons was kind of playing
this game
is not defaming then how is this and
they're saying that basically Tucker
Carlson and the rest of their prime time
slot you know people because that was
another answer stealing right that was
another anchor of their argument was
that it's just entertainment right right
but the problem is that Fox News has is
there's the news in the moniker right
this isn't called Tony Michael's news
right and we don't say we're bringing
you the news yeah and I'm reporting and
I'm a journalist I don't run around with
press credentials pretending to be a
[__] journalist we're we're
entertainment we're commentary that's
what we're doing
we're commentating on the the news and
trying to make it entertaining enough
for you to learn some things but it it
goes to show you that this is how uh
little prepared they were for this like
I don't think that they were expecting
much at all like they were literally
pulling
the right words
argument what could it be that that was
the worst best argument that had what
was it and that what it is with Will
Ferrell and Zach galvanakis yeah yeah
there's a and and they're like this is
the is this the best idea you got this
is the worst best idea we got boss this
is the the best worst idea we got like
this is a horrible idea but it's the
best one we got this one yeah and I
think honestly they're like well
we we got nothing like we have been
shown in the public we have been shown
through documents those files
transcripts a text message the emails
how much Fox News new
what they were doing they were
intentionally misleading Americans about
the election and then that was your
point right that was your point is that
that's what you really wanted to see in
the law yeah that's what would have been
bared out in the act right I wanted to
see Tucker Carlson on the stand answer
the questions about why he lied or or
Laura Ingraham or Sean Hannity I wanted
that [__] on the record now that's not
to say that it won't be on the record
right that it won't be something that
we'll we'll find out in the in the
smartmatic trial or if
um
if there's some other lawsuits that
include those people right you could
easily
find that that's that's what we get
which would be great right but it is one
of those things I'm like I would have
been great to like see that [__] right
like oh my God I I I would pay to watch
that that type of coverage right right
just like oh yeah for 10 bucks I'll pay
it every day
let's do it on core TV well speaking of
Fox News and it seems like they [__]
around and found out and now they're
they're paying the price right so
they're starting to dump some of these
uh conservative big contracts they got
damn bongino apparently got fired from
Fox News Boeing Geno I don't know I
don't know how he's is it bongino I
always call like mine
Mineo Dan bongino Dan bongino now
apparently um they say he's got he got
fired so now he would have some sort of
contributor contract and I'm sure
um at almost any point uh Fox News could
eliminate that you know like Sarah Palin
and a contributor contract for a while
they fired him he's got a contributor
contracts
you know they come on and you know
they're right now you won't lose your
show people you've never heard of get
you know it's almost like going from
Full that's where Kimberly Guilfoyle
came from after I know well after her
the sexual assaults or harassment that
she did onto another person at Fox News
that's why she was which was revealed in
these Fox files right which was amazing
because like I don't know how this came
out of this but I'm loving it so someone
uh Wu-Tang for children's getting a
calipa bongino here I think this is
about the Mar-A-Lago raid but you know I
I think it's probably it's probably that
they can't afford bongino anymore
because he's a [__] but you know he's
an expensive [__] I bet so but the
other the other expense they can't
afford with bongino is saying stupid
[__] on air like listen to this
I just want to say in closing listen
America they're laughing at you the left
thinks this is hilarious you doubt me
yeah come here [__]
I'll laugh at you all day it is
hilarious you know it's [__]
hilarious and I can't stop laughing at
you bongino come here and watch dude
I'll have you I laugh at these people
every day everyone else like oh they're
destroying our institution I was I was
amused yesterday when when Dan Goldman
and and uh Benny Thompson stuff [__]
Marjorie Taylor green in a goddamn trash
can on the rules in the committee [__]
yeah let's do that all day everyday
right [__] uh digiland I don't know
if I'm selling it right to Jalen to
Jalen anyway they say say it like
speaking of face plants Rhonda Santos
really [__] it up yesterday dude where
the [__] is Dan is is [__] Rhonda he
was in Washington DC not getting
endorsements that's where he was at dude
he got not in Florida he was in yeah I
saw Trump was bragging about how he
cleaned up in Florida
[__] man yes is there is there a [__]
truth out there I think there's him oh
let's let's show that if we can get it
yeah
um
um Jake
asked what will DeSantis Ben next
apparently himself he might ban himself
I mean he's nowhere to be found in
Florida he's an I know in Ohio he's in
Georgia he's in Washington DC because of
his failed non-presidential campaign
what a dumb [__]
he should have listened to me Gabe
Sanchez
[__] weeks ago it was it was the day
of the arraignment and I said Rhonda
Sanchez get the [__] out in front of
microphone resign now and announce your
run or you're done buddy you're [__]
toast this is it man this is your
opportunity and he did not
listening that's the that's what's going
on because what what's what is happening
is that during the debates for the
gubernatorial race he was asked straight
up are you running for a president do
you have plans to run for president in
the 2024 election and Chris Christie I
mean excuse me Charlie Christ yeah
Charlie Chris asking that and there's
another there's another Chris Christie
component to this because Chris we
showed that the other day and he is uh
and he's trying to
trying he's like oh well he's like look
he can't answer the question because he
knows he wants to and he couldn't he
couldn't say it and why would he because
he's running for governor and it would
be kind of shitty for someone to go I'm
running for governor of the state of
Florida but also within a few months of
me taking office I'm going to announce
that I'm leaving this position and going
to run for president right it's not a
great selling point when you're trying
to get people to vote for you and win an
election well Charlie Chris had a pretty
good strategy there but it didn't yeah
yeah it wasn't enough and right now
we're finding uh Ron DeSantis in a bit
of a pickle which is like the longer he
he waits is it a woke pickle is it a
woke one or is it it's a it's a woke
pickle
I just want to make sure yeah no it's a
great wolf pickle woke pickles are much
better than not oh yeah they're they
they for everyone who doesn't know they
definitely know who they are
and what they can offer but like you
look at this and like you know he gets
he gets sworn in in January and for his
last term and then uh now we have a
situation where the longer he waits the
worse it is for him because it's more
it's more attacks that he just has to
take without announcing I'm running and
go [__] yourself Donald Trump so he's in
this position where he can't say
anything because he can't announce
because he's still Governor which means
I mean he's only three months in to his
his current term right so it would be
something that's like oh yeah if you're
gonna announce like you'd wait until
later on well you you [__] step out
the front door you know Gabe Sanchez
that if he does he's only three months
in like you said to his governorship
yeah if he doesn't announce and he
[__] lays flat on this oh they have
to resign as Governor like oh done by
gun dude why would Florida want you to
be there Governor if your whole ambition
was to be president United States and
you couldn't get more than a couple
[__] endorsements out of Congress out
of Florida Congressman of all [__]
like Florida is where woke goes to die
and it's so great in Florida but you
can't round up a [__] couple dozen
Florida Congress people to endorse you
and not Donald Trump get out of here man
it's one of the it right now if you look
at the current situation like the [__]
show that he's in right now is he's not
you know very much like Ted Cruz right
abandons when [__] hits the fan but uh
Rhonda Santos is not in Florida there
you know there was flooding there's high
gas prices there's all these these these
uh
there's all of these terrible things
that are happening to to his
constituents to Floridians in Florida do
something which he should and that's his
responsibility as the governor to look
out for the people right but right now
where is he oh he's meeting with other
donors he's meeting with people in DC
he's trying to get this and he's trying
to have backroom deals like it's all
this stuff that's gonna backfire because
then because what's gonna happen is he's
[__] the bed in Florida so even if
he doesn't just in Florida just in
Florida right now well I mean in DC he
should have bet on the endorsements but
he's in he you know he can't even keep
his State afloat right it's literally
underwater Oh man and and what's gonna
happen is the longer he waits it's
trying you're trying to multitask
something where you don't have a good
control of either and in Florida he's
letting that [__] go awry and he can't
get it under control and then so that's
another that's going to be another
attacking point when when he if if if he
does because he's losing millionaire
donors at the same time if he does
announce and say I'm running for
president
the one of the biggest attack points
that he's gonna have is well how are you
going to take care of the country if you
couldn't take care of your own state
right you're supposed to do this on a
national scale if you couldn't even do
an electrical one well the other thing
too is is I mean Floridians got to be
going you know what you're not working
for us you're working for your own
[__] good right like you became
governor for you not for us it's the
same thing at some point the same same
people in Colorado who are now again are
talking about how Lauren bobert is not
not there to help support them she's
doing her own thing looking for fame
right I guarantee in this next election
she's [__] done oh well I mean she
was 500 votes and there's no way that
five a couple thousand people don't
[__] yeah yeah [__] her by the time
they find out speaking of Ron DeSantis
and his Banning and his war on stupidity
even even this dumbass Larry Kudlow on
Fox Business gets it right this is how
bad it is for Rhonda Santos listen to
this I just want to observe that
Governor DeSantis is close to making a
fool of himself with his Walt Disney
Obsession it's close yeah right I was
like what the [__] close
a hundred meter death down the road
right past that oh my God Disney's like
keep going friend yeah keep going you're
giving us all kinds of national press of
of being a being a a company of
inclusion yeah we care about people and
Universal building a state prison do a
private prison next to a place that's
for family and good right memories and
fun right everyone's like you know we
better go buy tickets to Disney before
the prison's built and Disney's like
yeah sure come on down
what the [__] okay he goes on in his his
panel digs into Ron DeSantis here too
this is on Fox Business folks I I want
to stress for a second Fox Business this
is their this is their stock market
channel right this is the channel That
all the people who think they're really
smart on crypto go watch
um so let's listen listen to the panel
here this has been going on now for
months and months and months and I would
argue that it is unseemly number one a
governor should not be come crashing him
down on if not the biggest one of the
biggest business I don't like Disney's
politics either their woke politics my
guess is Bob Iger is going to change
that but whatever I uh does Santa make a
deal and stop already he's not running
against Walt Disney for president no as
we've been saying yes no campaign skills
he can't debate and he can't negotiate
Donald Trump would be in a room with
Disney working this out to Santa's
problem was it was easy to slap Disney
around they had that dumb CEO but he's
gone Iger is here and DeSantis is no
match for Iger who's ten steps ahead of
DeSantis on there okay so that was our
commentary on Tuesday that was our
commentary and he's now now the whole
idea that somehow Donald Trump would get
in a room with Disney this is really
stupid that's the dumbest thing I would
love I would love I would love to watch
Brian beiger [__] chew Donald Trump
up one second walk he walk in and be
like I'm fighting for you you know and
also the [__] woke they're not woke
policies it's just [__] being
inclusive right I mean like they don't
wow they don't want their employees to
be pissed off at him right exactly and
they got a lot of lgbtq allies and that
part of the community in their employ
employee base they don't want their
employees to walk out on them you've
dumb son's a [__] right and it's
called it's called capitalism
together
what the [__] is wrong with these people
Republicans again Republicans you have a
short-sighted they don't future proof
they attack without thinking about how
the corporation that they don't like and
they're being upset about is actually a
big time donor in their party or to
their own campaign they you know the the
policies are actually ones that a
majority of Americans agree with it's
not woke right it's not bad it's it's
actually good and the fact that you know
like I pointed out on Tuesday there were
over 77 000 people that are employed in
the Disney World
area okay like all of Orlando and the
other thing too is if you're not
employed by Disney in Orlando wherever
you are employed is probably benefited
Yeah by Hospitality being there you work
at a hotel that's outside of anything
yeah anything yeah restaurant whatever
it might be you are different Universal
Studios wherever it is it is an economy
uh uh generator right it is one where it
is a job Creator if you take that away
you take that [__] like right core of
energy away
that area is [__] done no one's gonna
come back down there no one's gonna be
going to your hotels No One's Gonna be
going to your Spas No One's Gonna Be
Coming to Your restaurants No One's
Gonna be renting your cars don't you be
flying in error anymore you mean it'll
just turn back into swamp land as well
it'll just [__] take over I mean no
one will go to the Orlando Magic games
Florida's already flooding so like if
they leave and no one's there to take
care of it because I guarantee Walt
Disney like the Walt Disney Company
itself that owns Disney World and that
and that that area they're the ones who
are maintaining they're making sure I
mean there's a whole
there's the uh uh well
if you remember about how they run
Disney World it's the whole like making
sure that even the even one cigarette
butt right or whatever one piece of
trash or litter whatever it's picked up
within seconds but you know where that
comes from I talked about it the other
day that comes from Roy Disney yeah well
and Walt was really [__] particular
too did you you know this story so this
is actually my my one of my former VP of
design that I used to work at a company
he would tell me stories about how the
dynamic that Roy in walted right right
wrote was always all the money he was
like all right that's how we're gonna
Finance he's a businessman what was like
all right how do we create by the way I
don't live well there well I don't want
to say something because it's going to
reveal where I live so never mind uh it
has to do with Disney anyway
um but there was a there was a a dynamic
that they had where Roy would go out of
out of town for business right he would
go deal with whatever
and Walt Walt would work on these little
tiny fixes and it's like it's this whole
concept of leveling up so they're like
oh we're gonna go paint the tips of the
castle gold like little things that
people wouldn't say that cost money it
costs money but if you notice if you're
like oh wow that's actually pretty cool
so there's all these things that that
Walt Disney did while Roy was off like
off doing business stuff Walt would get
other people and be like look we're
gonna level this [__] up right because
Roy wouldn't let him do it because Rory
is like no you don't have the money yeah
you want the money you don't have the
money you don't have to help people how
many times Roy would say I don't we
don't have the money we don't have the
money on a daily basis how many times so
we should get Abigail Disney on and ask
her if she knows some of this yeah that
is so I I can imagine countless times
where he would go to an employee and be
like hey we're gonna go paint this gold
and he's like yeah but Rory said don't
worry about what Roy said he's off he he
already approved Roy's not here
[__] Roy comes back and he's
like what what's up what they said and
he was like oh no look look people are
gonna look he's like No One's Gonna
notice it but again people
is what they are today because of that
dynamic between now I will I'll say that
um so Walt Disney
um the stories go like this because I
I've read several biographies of Walt
Disney and there's there's some really
there's some things about Walt Disney
that are not good right I mean we're all
human Walt Disney was a human now some
people claim he was anti-Semitic the
biographers that that I've done some of
them claim it some of them don't it's
kind of fuzzy of what it was but Walt
Disney sure expected the best out of
anyone who was in front of him and he
would say as much he would say this is
this is is this the best you can do yeah
like they would give him a product and
he would say is this the best you can do
and they they're like well maybe not and
then they'd have to go make it better
and then they bring it back and he's
like is this the best you can do right
and they bring it back I mean it's a
very it's a very Steve Jobs like type of
mentality where it's like here's a
design and it's like but we can make it
better I mean he didn't if Walt Disney
was like in the rocket business they
would probably wouldn't explode yeah
they probably you wouldn't have sockets
you wouldn't understand
I gotta find a clip but there's a clip
of of Elon where talking about the shape
of the rocket and why it's pointy go
find it yes because let's go to that
well I want to show you this um back to
Ron DeSantis and and Donald Trump's riff
this is Shadow across the Bell now he
doesn't he doesn't say Rhonda Santos his
name in this post
um but we all know what he's talking
about here he says a great group of
supportive Florida congressmen and
congresswomen
all who have endorsed with a capital E
me I'm surprised him but me like are
your favorite President of all time
Donald J Trump
um he goes on to say we'll be coming to
Mar-A-Lago tonight ours not not to
Tallahassee to Mar-A-Lago yeah that's
important our support is almost
Universal in Florida and throughout the
USA he's like [__] Ron the Sanctus
um this anus I think that's where he's
gonna go with it this anus this anus so
he goes on to say they remember finally
all the incredible things I did while in
office one of them most successful
administrations in history there it is
there it is baby there's the [__]
you need waiters for this one he said
we'll be a great night so he's basically
telling Ronda zantes he can go [__]
himself hey buddy hey Ronnie so um today
wild be there right jaytay to your
question what will the Santa spend next
himself yeah it'll power probably be
himself is what he'll he'll ban next is
this the clip that you got this is the
clip okay which is the biggest
the biggest okay look Elon Musk I'm a
genius uh the guy's a [__] idiot
which we've already covered many many
times since whoa whoa whoa you know how
much money this guy actually I think
that much I can't be that too but he has
that much money I think we're we're
entering a year now of covering Elon
Musk being a [__] idiot is it a year
I think it's because it was around March
April or something like that of last
year when he was like oh this would be
funny if I paid 50.
if I if I overpay for Twitter by 30
billion dollars that'd be hilarious it's
funny it's funny it's funny when you
think about that because you're like oh
you wouldn't have to cut employees cut
costs sell furniture from the office not
pay your landlord
um and also maybe the Rockets wouldn't
explode in midair too also if you were
to cut all those things plus the
compensation that you promised to pay
people when they were laid off uh maybe
if you didn't pay over by by 30 billion
dollars then you wouldn't have had to do
those things and you won't have to pay a
billion and a half plus interest every
year to the banks for your 13 billion
dollar loan that you got right like it's
not to mention the money that you
obviously you know you have to repay to
the Saudis and other people that have a
best interest in this but you would
think that if you didn't make a joke
about paying 54.20 because again 420
it's on 420. it's still 20. for sure if
you didn't do that then you wouldn't be
in the financial [__] show that you're
in right now and again Elon Musk is a
[__] idiot who doesn't know how to
run a business who's never invented or
created something from scratch by
himself he's always bought something got
government assistance and also take
taken or purchased technology of other
companies and then acquire that into his
own company he hasn't created something
he hasn't built anything from scratch
even [__] PayPal wasn't done from
scratch with him okay there were other
people like Peter Thiel and [__]
other other uh
uh uh blinking on his name but anyway
other other people you know of the
PayPal Mafia that group those are the
people that were involved Elon Musk
wasn't his idea and maybe contributed
some code here and there but like wasn't
anything impressive and this [__]
clip that we're about to show you is an
example of how dumb Elon Musk is and how
much of a self-own this is from what he
reveals when he goes on to uh Joe
Rogan's podcast so Paul says before we
go to this clip Paul says on YouTube
says Elon is a promoter Paul he may
pretend to be a promoter but he pretends
to be a lot of things he pretends to be
a rocket scientist he pretends to be a
business entrepreneur he's he's a
spoiled little brat is what he is and
and we support his bratam it that it is
but here's here's this clip from uh
Rogan's podcast here let's listen what
is he drinking there
Jesus Christ
he looks really chubby there right am I
wrong yeah this is like before the
picture where he was on the yacht I
don't know when this was yeah well this
is this is Joe Rogan this is so Joe
Rogan moved to Austin and he had this
like spaceship studio and people were
like we don't like the spaceship studio
and so then he redesigned the studio to
the one that it is right now oh okay
where it's got the big sign in the back
behind him so wait he cut he cucked
because of his Studio yeah I haven't
touched yet everyone everyone's talking
about the the [__] Shadow up here dude
always amazing keep the [__] so
okay so here here's here's Elon in this
spaceship Studio that and Rogan cut on
let's listen you literally told them to
make the Starship more pointy because of
the movie dictator
oh [__] Jesus Christ
this smile on the faces of Dan and they
know it too it's not like they it's not
like they haven't they're unaware of it
it runs sort of be funny if we made the
rock and roll pointy so we did did it
have any effect on the aerodynamics no
nothing now we can make it way blunter
and be fine but is it better to be
pointier like if it wasn't for this
arguably slightly worse
oh my God arguably slightly worse one
might say that the reason that his
rockets explode is because they can't
get in the [__] air the rocket
scientists then had to look at the Rock
and say God damn it this isn't even
aerodynamic and I've got a [__]
placate to this dude's weird again again
from what movie the [__] [__]
dictator which is a whole [__]
satirical piece about dictators it's
making fun of people like there's even a
scene where he's like Elon like Elon
where he's given a scene where there's a
scene and we can't play because it'll
it'll get flagged but there's a scene
where where uh Sasha Baron Cohen as the
dictator is talking to these different
world leaders and I think Americans as
well and he's like look as as a world as
a dictator you can do this and this and
this and this and this and he's
basically describing what billionaires
and the super wealthy do with politics
and power and influence in America
and when people watching like oh that's
so funny and it's like dude he's
literally making fun of you in the movie
right and then you've got
you've got uh uh you've got Elon Musk
who's like oh well we want to make it
pointy because the movie uh the dictator
and it's like okay so he never got the
jokes in the movie and also he decided
to make
the rocket arguably
less or or rather arguably worse by
making it pointy because it's not
aerodynamic and the rocket science is
like [__] man [__] not just the rocket
scientist I mean like the rocket itself
watch this [__] here's the rocket and
this is the very last launch this is
what happened in mid-air icing on the
cake
why are they cheering I don't know who's
cheering icing on the cake
yeah unless it works what well they
called it a rapid unscheduled
disassembly which is what is what they
were calling it's an explosion it blew
up it blew the [__] up
[Music]
oh my God I'm just
it's like one of those things where
you're like man
this guy gets Government funding
to blow up rockets and I was like woohoo
you know and it's like all right yeah
billions of dollars right we're making
reusable Rockets it's our money that
he's blowing up our money and he's like
haha they're pointy huh it's a joke
right and they know it
yeah are you [__] me
because because why because he's a small
little [__] yeah I mean that's what I
think a spoiled little [__] whose
family made money off gem minds and
[__] South Africa and didn't work a
day in his life to make what he has
again he purchased things he contributed
little he stole ideas I mean how much
how much did the federal government give
in subsidies to SpaceX uh you know I
don't know I mean they have well every
year in with a B I think
is what the total amount of subsidies I
think they've given to SpaceX I believe
Government funding it says SpaceX alone
has got this is as of five days ago it
says a whopping 2.8 billion in
government contracts last year that's
just like according to the information
it has gotten a total of 15.3 billion
since 2003. so in the last 20 years last
20 years they've gone 15.3 billion I
thought it was like five but it's right
but also it's like yeah then you're like
oh you're getting contracted work by
NASA to build these Rockets as you know
space travel right
yeah because this isn't this isn't like
um you know this it's our
out like like here on this earth right
lifestyle this is to send Rich
[__] right into space
well I I was gonna say I get some people
like are excited about space travel like
the idea that a normal average person
could travel into space or whatever the
[__]
um but this is like tourism right like
this is right yeah it's I mean it's
consumer tourism like you everyone was
like oh is it gonna be you know you've
got uh Blue Sky I think it's but the
thing is called Blue Sky right
which is
um wait is that called Blue Sky hold on
I'm gonna show you this um here's here's
um
here's the actual launch of it from CNN
this is their coverage of it uh but
actually taken off and you can see it's
the rocket it's the rocket that that was
shown in the [__] Joe Rogan clip
where he's talking about pointing
Rockets like they didn't change it after
that you know yeah they realized it was
slightly worse they kept it they kept
the design I mean they were forced to
keep the design
dragon
so there it goes
now the accomplishment I'm going to turn
this down I'm going to turn the sound
off the accomplishment here really is is
that this is as far as I know this is
the biggest hunk of metal that anyone
has tried to [__] throw into space
right yeah now it was unsuccessful yeah
yeah but it is this is the attempt at
the biggest
um
the biggest rocket that's ever been
thrown into space now again this is Elon
taking every single bit of credit for
this rocket and really honestly that's
why because there's a lot of people's
hard work behind this rocket let's not
let's not ignore that there's a lot of
people serious [__] people who tried
to make this thing work even with this
[__] at the helm of this thing who's
going to take credit for all this and
that's why I'm gonna give him credit for
the [__] thing blowing up in midair
and yeah I mean look if you get if you
get credit or blame for Success right
you get the same treatment for failure
you're the face in the head of the
company and you want to be like oh yes
SpaceX blah blah blah this [__] you
are going to be the same you you take on
both sides man you bring that same
energy if you're going to be doing that
right
um but blue oh yeah so blue blue origin
Christopher Garcia I just looked it up
oh nope sorry that's the wrong one uh
blue origin is the name of the Amazon or
is the is the Jeff Bezos one then yeah
yeah yeah then you've got uh the dick
Rockets because yeah Bezos thinks it's a
good idea to make them look like dicks
blue balls that's what we call it uh
then you got Richard Branson who I guess
would be the the the better of the three
that are making Rockets but yes they're
consumer travel uh in terms of like
tourism and then you've got Elon Musk
and you have to realize that it's like
you know maybe Richard Branson has more
of like a a genuine interest in like
space travel but you look at just just
uh just you know bird's eye view you
look at billionaires creating Rockets to
get out of Earth and it's like
maybe that says something about
their own kind of um
perception of
of of our country or our planet rather
right they would much rather leave the
planet
then stay here and fix it well I'll tell
you the reason why Richard Branson is
probably a little more serious about
this because he's been a [__]
billionaire longer than right Elon and
Jeff Bezos could dream of
um he's been a billionaire for a long
time uh a long time so I want to move to
a different story I'd love to talk about
um
hell
elon's rocket exploding in mid-air for a
long time but I just can't did you did
you see who else face planted uh
yesterday and it was Matt Walsh in Iowa
did you see this no what no are you
[__] [__] me oh no I didn't see
any of this I the last I heard of Matt
Walters when I was when I texted you and
I was like dude his account got hacked
oh no well I mean which by the way which
by the way I don't know if you saw that
stuff but Elon is uh the reporter who
spoke and did an article he spoke with
the actual hacker and did an article for
I think that hired that hacked that
hacked his account from other people he
uh he did it he did an interview and was
like look like what was the you know
let's talk about this right and he did
an interview with him and then that
reporter that journalist
put the link up and he's like hey I
spoke to the hacker this is what he had
to say blah blah blah blah
and then that dude's account
Dell is the journalist
got [__] suspended from Twitter oh
Jesus for promoting promoting yeah I
mean like you mean a story
yeah for promoting hacking or right
come on man yeah come on I mean even
even you know uh Ollie Alexander like
that guy got [__] suspended as well
and it's like dude I thought we were all
about Free Speech man nope I want to see
I want to see more of this [__] hitting
the fan yeah
you're like trying to trying to
cauterize the wound so it doesn't bleed
out anymore
to be like oh no we can't have more of
this on the platform it's like I thought
it was all about Free Speech man
what happened to you guys letting the
[__]
[__] [__] just flow
you want to see freedom and speech in
action yeah so Matt Walsh goes to the
University of Iowa right
and and the P the students there at Iowa
there's a bunch of them that wanted a
bunch of the bigoted students that want
to go listen to Matt Walsh almost every
single one of them are male and white
can you imagine
um but Aaron Reed has this video here it
says amazing actions are happening right
now
watch this Matt Walsh at the University
of Iowa someone poured thousands of
marbles forcing the Walsh bands to walk
through the exit with protesters forcing
them to walk extremely slow so basically
they could be shouted at right they
couldn't run away yeah yeah video of the
look at all these Marbles and I don't
know if you ever walked across floor
with a bunch of Mario you're gonna have
to make sure you don't you know it's
kind of it's kind of funny like like
with the um Home Alone situation right
all right Marvin Harry coming to the
entryway and there's like the the
Matchbox cars are over the floor yeah
flip and fall you know that's kind of
the oversell of it the the The Three
Stooges type setup which by the way I
just want to talk home alone is like a
child like it's like a like a kids die
hard right okay like that's
it's it's die hard for kids that's right
it's called what it is but here in true
Home Alone fashion they dump marbles all
over this floor yeah and it's at the
steps of this one entrance and the
reason why is because they wanted to be
able to shout at these [__]
supporters and basically tell them what
they feel about them so the so the
anti-mat Walsh people were outside or
they were right inside no they're
outside shouting okay but they wanted to
make sure that they either had to leave
through the entrance where the where the
protesters were set up or they had to
walk so slowly that right all right but
but the funny part is is and I I quote
tweeted this I said these marbles kill
fascism
[Laughter]
I mean how smart is this you got a slick
tile floor a bunch of marbles tiny balls
taken down weak boys right isn't that
funny how marbles are taken down man
it's really it's it's actually it's
pretty funny to think about like the
simplest things marbles whistles right
yelling
listen loud noises when you can't run
away from a whistle because there's
marbles on the floor boom win loud
noises are the fascist Kryptonite here's
an example this is the same this is at
University of Iowa this is a pep band
playing and shouting something see if
you can make out what they they're
saying here in Gabe Sanchez
[Music]
there's a whistle there too by the way
yeah yeah so now um you're you're from
the Midwest so you'll understand that
High School marching band and Batmans
are a thing that we have here in the
Midwest yeah so I'm sure they're all
around the country but it's a it's a
very important thing
um I mean also if you have a if you have
a band a marching band it's like man
you're rolling in deep you know right
like they're cut like they're loud too
you got brass they got sound they got
they got the [__] bass drums the
tubas I mean they're loud right so I
mean naturally a marching band is a
fascist worst enemy really honestly oh
it's just about how loud they are and
how loud they can be you know drowning
these loud noises are are fancy script
tonight
um oh my ears oh my Nazi ears they're so
sensitive you know how sensitive Nazi
ears are oh my God okay here's a now
let's see this is uh I'm gonna play the
other one oh yeah here's so here's um
um here's one one point where they can't
go nowhere because like these students
the protesters like blocked the road and
[__] and they can't really go anywhere
right so they're kind of like stranded
yeah right and they don't like loud
noises so we'll watch this this is where
the the the Matt Walsh simps are
Stranded by loud noises watch this and
they're terrified they gotta they need a
safe space really away from these loud
noises I mean margin Taylor green said
on Sean Hannity show a little while
right in March April or March she was
like we need to save space we need a
place that we could be protected all
right really from loud noises because
she needed to be protected from loud
noises in New York City but here's the
Matt wall Simpsons uh at the University
of Iowa needed a safe space from those
loud liberal noises
do you see the theme let me let me turn
that do you see a theme over here of
these oh look at these look at these
dudes yeah look at these dudes I don't
see uh they look pissed off man all
right you know what they also look you
know what they also look like they all
look white I was just gonna say you know
I honestly I am not seeing any melanin
in that crowd and you don't see many I
mean there's a few there's a few
um of the other gender over there you'd
say but um you know I don't I don't want
to I don't want to say pronouns because
I might upset these simps right like
there's some with the pronouns she or
her over there on the other side but
most of them are he hims
well she's loud noises Matt Walsh is
right about these loud noises they're
scary
I'm gonna call my dad to pay for my mom
for me to be here at Iowa University I
feel like they're all those
all those dudes are a bunch of like
heavy breathing Bros who just it was
like I'm gonna go to the gym we're gonna
sound later you want to spot me bro like
those are the dude is that is that what
they say in the gym that's what they do
man I mean I'll admit when I'm lifting
I'll Grunt and [__] yeah but it but it's
because I'm I'm working hard to try to
lift the weight not because I not
because I I think I think it's cooler
like maybe it's not because it's not
because they're they're grunting because
they're actually working out there's
like okay you know
this is the best representation uh you
see these guys at the gym all the time
but there was one specific time I was at
the gym and I was at the squat rack and
there was a guy who was who was on the
bench and he'd like set up the plates
and he said
and he like put the stuff up so he's
doing that as he said yeah like he's
he's like he gets not like when he's
lifting yeah you know he like gets him
he gets him 45s throws him on the bar in
his room and then he like
take his pre-workout you know so I can
C4 [__] and he like he like goes down he
like so I'm the squad racks are against
the wall with all the mirrors and then
behind me is where the bench the benches
and so he like goes down to one end of
the the gym and then the other and he's
like yeah he's just like so he's trying
to get himself yeah okay I was like all
right fine you're probably yourself did
he lay it on his chest
no no no so what happened was then he
goes back to the bars like grabs another
cup of 45s throws him on the bar so
right now we've got 180 plus 45 so we're
at 2 uh 225. and and so I was like wow
that's a that's a lot of weight this
guy's going for a PR at Sea yeah I was
like this is a lot so he does the same
thing right he chugs a little more in
his little mixed drink and he goes down
and comes back and he's got a routine
and then he gets down he gets on the
bench and he like
does it and he like he uh he curls his
back up and he's like boom it like
flattens the back out and they put his
hands then he measures out and then he's
like
and then and then he drops him he drops
him and then he slides out he's like
and then he does this thing again like
another two times another two times he I
think he might have added another like
25 or so on each side
he he finished his whole like
[__] pump up moment right he got down
to the bench and he's like whoa and then
left and then he's like Ric Flair
and then he just left and he never he
never actually lifted the weight he
never actually did it that's hilarious
and then and then and then he was but he
was also the [__] who left all the
weight back on he left it on the bar he
didn't take it off well you know you
know who who couldn't also finish and
leave
Iowa University he couldn't oh yeah well
he's trying to leave yeah Matt Walsh
couldn't know this is no Matt Walsh
couldn't leave uh Iowa University here
because the students sat in the [__]
driveway
and [__] couldn't leave that's
funny so he's so he's trapped there's
there's the picture of it I think
there's a video of this too let me let
me see if I can go find the video yeah
so he's trapped yeah here's the uh
here's them walking out into the uh into
the road to block him so that he
couldn't go that way he can't hide from
the loud noises I mean people are just
crossing the street legally and that's
what I see look they're using the
crosswalk I don't know that's right
nothing illegal about this well
if you look here there and let me turn
the sound off and you can see they're
making a circle see there's a crosswalk
back here I get it they're making a big
sorry yeah they're like this is again
nothing illegal about it right you gotta
yield attitude for pedestrians
pedestrians have the right of way sorry
right right you know
[__] Matt Walsh I'm with so is Matt
Walsh in this car right here or is he
someone well no I I I don't think he got
anywhere near the loud noises I mean
let's let's again it's Kryptonite they
they get close to the loud noises they
they may you know lose their fascist
nazi straight right right okay so they
can't get close to where the where the
loud noises are so I'm sure he was way
back away from the loud noises we
wouldn't we wouldn't want him uh to lose
his Nazi superpowers no no not at all
right not at all I mean look I mean
today's a bit I don't know if you know
this Tony but today is a very important
day really for for fast
is marijuana day right but it's also
it's also Hitler's birthday yeah there
we go yeah yeah so big day in the Kanye
West Harlan Pro okay yeah household you
know Nick Fuentes he likes Nikki Fuentes
um right Charlie Kirk yeah
well I mean Michael Knowles Ben Shapiro
the fact that he you know he defended
right defended yeah he's like dude
Hitler's cool Hitler's cool man you can
collect Hitler's [__] I mean you know
you could stand for Hitler no make
Hitler Hitler capes Hitler posters oh
man it's not like if I were in a room
with Hitler right now Hitler would try
to kill me you know right like that's
gonna happen that's crazy
I'm on his side it's not like it's not
like uh
Hitler didn't kill Jews that were Nazis
no he didn't do that at all not at all
yeah but you know Ben Shapiro going hey
guys it's totally cool to collect
dictator memorabilia and statues and
Hitler first today or run a Nazi not run
a Nazi Network yeah like daily wire Mr
Mr back on YouTube so there's more
cowbell God damn right get out the
[__] noise and make noise these
people they are they are terrified
terrified of loud noises that's why they
don't like this show game I got a fever
I got a fever and the only cure the only
prescription
yeah small cowbell more cowbell [__]
and you know we're gonna be allowed here
on the Tony Michaels podcast every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch don't forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
right now you're not going to want to
miss a thing tomorrow's Friday what the
[__] happens on Friday
boot of the week tomorrow in the second
hour make sure to go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod I'm hoping
you'll be able to vote I don't know if
elon's changed this or not but nope it's
still there I checked last night good it
is still there so so you'll still be
able to vote on Twitter and on YouTube
so you'll be able to vote for bone of
the week bone of the week you vote you
decide who is the bone Hen of the week
and on Friday in the second hour we
break it down for you the audience who
you picked as bone Hen of the week also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google make sure to go over
to the Facebook page follow us over
there at the Tony Michaels and if you
got an Amazon Prime account you can tie
it to your Twitch account and give us a
few of Amazon's money that's right Gabe
Sanchez if you have an Amazon Prime
account and you link it to Twitch right
you get one free subscription with that
Prime account
and if you give it to us the Tony
Michaels podcast over on Twitch we get a
couple dollars of Jeff bezos's money
from the rocket that's right into our
accounts we get dildo Rockets money
that's what we get now every single
month every single month you have to
renew this subscription over on Twitch
so if you've done this before hear me if
you have given us your subscription on
Twitch before you have to go back over
there and give it
but it doesn't cost you a single thing
other than a little bit of time it takes
to renew this subscription every month
so go back over there if you've done it
before renew your subscription or if you
have an Amazon Prime account make sure
to give us that subscription on Twitch
by linking your accounts also don't
forget I'm sure there's going to be a
new what was that coming soon yeah
there's there's a there's what was that
I'm working on right now which is about
Donald Trump's grifting cards that he
has uh the two the the 2.0 version the
second series it's uh it's more pathetic
and just as dumb it is Don Jr what was
that show.com that's what was that
show.com it'll take you directly to
Gabe's patreon or you can go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez while
you're on patreon checking out what was
that over there make sure to come over
to my page and check out the patreon
party
come over come on over come on over
patreon.com the Tony Michaels that's
patreon.com the Tony Michaels we
appreciate all the monetary support that
you give us over on patreon that's what
keeps us loud into this microphone every
single weekday noon Eastern 119 Pacific
same time same place tomorrow Friday
bone end of the week
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon